don't go anywhere being in a bald eagle
nest is surreal
this is a wild animal she's being rowdy
it's very capable of hurting you if
you're not careful that you have to take
your time a little rough huh
sorry it's an experience that's hard to
describe my name is Jim Campbell Spitler
I'm a forest canopy ecologist and a
wildlife biologist and I'm pretty sure I
have the best job in the world my job is
to climb into the eagle's nest and
capture and work with chicks yeah the
monster and the reason why we're doing
this is we're trying to get blood
samples and we can use those blood
samples to look at environmental
contaminants and how they get into the
bald eagles food source and make me
chase you huh don't you come off there
come down it's a challenging species to
work with it's got a really sharp hook
to beak and its talons are big and
powerful and you don't want to let them
grab ahold of you because they can
really do some damage all right let's go
down this is a wild animal so you never
know what can happen the Channel Islands
are an island chain off the coast of
Southern California
these folks are looking off they're a
desert island system if you get out
there and you can stand on top of these
Bluffs and you can see the Pacific a
whole 360 degree view of just the most
beautiful ocean you can ever imagine
you've got not only bald eagles you have
peregrine falcons that are nesting on
the sea cliff just tell me if she's
coming in you've got a host of different
seabirds and it's just a magical place a
research it may look invasive but really
one of our primary concerns is the
safety of these young birds that were
handling so we go to great lengths to
ensure that we don't injure them and
that when we put them back in the nest
they're just as well off as when we
first encountered those likes you bald
eagles are national birds so it's quite
an honor for me to get to work with this
species quite often I'll just sit in
that nest for a moment and just take in
the view and just think wow you know
it's just an honor to get up there be
able to share that view and that
experience with them just for that
moment in time
[Music]
when you Highline often you really learn
to train your fear like a muscle
sometimes the height isn't the scariest
part
sometimes it's the exposure which is how
much space you can perceive around you
[Music]
my name is face Vicky and I'm a
professional slackliner so slacklining
is the umbrella term for all the
different facets of walking on a flat
woven band one of these facets is
highlining
which is walking a slackline high off
the ground one of the best ways to train
for highlining
is setting up slack lines over water
when the current is passing underneath
you you automatically start to follow
that same direction and it's almost like
you're not in control of your body and
that's great practice for highlining
because in high lining when you're
dealing with all the fear in adrenaline
oftentimes it feels like you're not in
control of your own body either
[Music]
Chameli is a town and the out of France
and it's one of the places that really
drives me in I line what's different
about highlighting in the Alps is that
the whole experience is more intense
being that high off the ground you look
at the valley below and the houses are
just tiny specks they look like toys
it's unbelievable one of the high lines
that I walked recently in Xiamen II was
on AG using MIDI and when we reached the
top it was a totally creative blue sky
and we were surrounded by peaks but
during the process of breaking the
clouds started to roll in it was like an
acid trip walking the line I was out
there in space and exposure trying to
balance and the line was clean beneath
me meanwhile these huge white clouds
were passing and the line would
disappear the anchor would disappear and
then it would reappear and there was no
way to control it I just had to hang on
yeah the beauty of the mountains is
awesome and yet it is a landscape that
demands focus and respect Alpine
highlining
is the purest form of the sport I can
think of
[Music]
if you're afraid of coming down and
going swimming in the ocean because of
sharks you should be terrified to make a
piece of toast 400 people died last year
from defective toasters whereas less
than 10 did from shark this is the first
large shark expedition like this in the
western Gulf will be tagged in
hammerhead sharks tiger sharks and mako
sharks trying to understand how they're
leveraging the Gulf and their birthing
mating and full migratory pattern will
be getting up every day just before dawn
the fishing team will be going out
getting all of our lines rigged and
ready to go and then we'll get the ship
in position with a lift in the water and
we'll be looking to capture bring sharks
back to the lift lift them up out of the
water and once we do that a whole team
of scientists from a half dozen
institutions will circle around the
shark and will conduct 12 research
projects in about 15 minutes then
release the shark and open source the
tracking to the world so that everyone
can follow it
what we're finding is that these massive
sharks have huge huge movements across
the ocean we have one of these white
sharks Lydia who's traveled over 35,000
miles in just two years very very
regular for these sharks to be swimming
a thousand miles a month which is why
it's so important to figure out where
they go
we're losing 200,000 sharks a day for
shark fin soup a hundred million a year
you know people need to understand an
ocean with no sharks means an ocean with
no fish they are the lion the balance
keeper of the ocean and if they are not
there the whole food chain collapses
this is a simple battle we got to solve
the puzzle of these sharks lives to make
sure they flourish and make a difference
for the future
[Music]
feeling cold is physically painful it
hurts your fingers it hurts your feet it
hurts your face it's also potentially
very life-threatening
my focus really is anything cold so if
there is ice or snow or cold breeze I
want to go there but I have focused
mostly on the polar regions both in the
Arctic and Antarctic only 48 people have
completed the unsupported unaided
expedition in North Pole compared to
Mount Everest where 6,000 people have
summited it's the most difficult
expedition on the planet to place a few
people understand a lot of what we see
an expedition the Artic ocean is nothing
it's like being on the inside of a ping
pong ball basically you can't see any
sort of differentiation from the sky to
the horizon to the snow surface it's
also incredible to look out on a clear
day and see the sheets of ice that are
wrapped together like blocks as big as
houses pressured in these amazing
incredible shapes you can't help but
just stop and be amazed this is my third
expedition the North Pole the Arctic
Ocean is changing very quickly compared
to a lot of other places scientists
estimate that the Arctic Ocean will be
ice-free
in less than 50 years in the summertime
unfortunately we find ourselves not
doing these adventures because they're
there anymore but because they might not
be there in the future our North Pole
trip realistically may be the last of
its kind of history and so it was very
important for me to do this adventure so
that people have an idea of what this
place is like right now so that we can
look back and say this is what we want
at
[Music]
you
[Music]